the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so what I want to do is continue talking
about risk we've already talked about
risk quite a bit last time what I want
to do partly is sort of emphasize some
specific point and I think partly go
over some of the ideas that have to do
with a community sharing its own risk
so rather than this risk through formal
insurance markets talk about what
happens if people try to ensure each
other and there but what that does is it
creates a nice context for thinking and
thinking about institutions in general
and how you know peep the fact that
people live together how that might
actually change there I think it's the
display settings I think we need to move
to ok so how the fact that people live
together in one place and have to deal
with each other on a long-run basis how
that affects the ways in which they
occur they can structure their economic
lives to help each other so it gets into
a question which is beyond I think
moving us beyond what we've usually been
talking about which is individual
decision-making towards a more
collective action kind of perspective so
we want to slowly move towards not just
what happens at the level of the
individual or why doesn't the
collectivity together generate good
outcomes and this is a good in in into
that question so we're going to talk so
I'll give you an a set of examples of
collective action and we start talking
about a bit about the collective efforts
to improve things I'm not sure what when
what's happening or figure this out so
the first I think first just to remind
you we were talking about risk and in
particular the fact that poor people
face extremely high levels of risk
listen I mean relative to and I'll show
you I said that yesterday and I'll show
you today I'll show you some numbers on
that just just just to get us on to that
just to summarize where we were last
time what we talked about primarily
we're sort of both that the poor faced a
lot of risk and that they do a lot of
things to mitigate risk but those things
are not necessarily good for them so the
examples we talked about or for example
going to work when your income goes down
but when you go to work when your income
goes down typically that's when
everybody else has income also end down
so they also go all go to work that
drives wages down and makes everybody
who potentially worse off
so in print in principle this and the
second example maybe Rita what's another
example of a costly thing you could do
to mitigate risk yeah form several
pieces of mind forever so that they
don't have the same risk profile
you could choose not to take a croc that
might be more successful because you're
worried that if you spend money to buy a
new seat and it doesn't turn out to be
as successful then we lose more money
and if you just used your scenes from
any other
she's enum fucha different jobs that
specialize anyone
yep choosing a bunch of different jobs I
was doing one why don't you why do you
want to specialize
more skill so you give up sorry
efficient example you just get better
okay so I think you can see the logic of
this so the question is we already
talked a bit about the kind of the
market for insurance what we didn't talk
as much about is why don't people help
each other you know one solution to this
problem is just helping each other and
so the illogic of helping each other is
very very simple
we each get maybe independent sharks and
so it's quite likely that you know when
somebody else gets a shock I don't and
vice-versa so we can kind of split the
shock so anything bad happens we don't
bear all of it we can pass on a part of
it to somebody else
it seems straightforward so why don't we
why doesn't that solve most problems
that's sort of the question we're going
to spend some time thinking about it
it's a very simple idea right we we
don't need to go to an insurance company
you can just pull together our own risk
hospitalization costs
I travel people are you going to pull
together
sometimes people think that they
shouldn't have to
what should we as many as possible
if why as many as possible is that it's
more estrella right so if we think that
example if you know the probability here
let's say they have independent
probabilities to people they have a
probability you know of a quarter that
they both end up with a bad shock right
well what's up what's that probability
if there were n people
think about what was the point the
problem is half that I think you mean
yeah just inverted the exponents it's 1
over 2 to the power n you just think
you're writing it in yeah it's 1 over 2
to the power n so as n goes to infinity
the number of people who who get shocks
together is going to 0 so that's sort of
very simple idea so question is why
doesn't it happen and that's sort of
what we're going to spend our time
talking about so we it does happen
the first answer is it does happen
here's a nice nice example and it says
something about actually saying
interesting example so turns out that
that the way it works in Nigeria I don't
actually give you money I don't actually
give you money when something bad
happens to you what do I do
I know you money and in particular I if
you are and if you are expected to pay
me back I ask for Less pay back if I am
expected to pay you back I pay you more
than what I was supposed to you so it's
I think of a we usually interest
contracts tend to be completely
inflexible right and you know I pay back
I pay back my mortgage is whatever 5.4%
I pay five or four percent every year
till the mortgage is paid that's not
what credit looks like it not in Nigeria
in these villages he found that you know
the interest rate itself is very
flexible so I I pay more than what I
owed in some sense when the interest
rate is when you are doing badly and I
pay less than what I ought when you're
doing well that's a way to provide
insurance but it goes through this cover
of a loan
okay perfectly good question we'll come
back let's come back to that I want to
spend a minute before we get to that
question on a more basic question which
is why do you think they do this well
what what's different about so what's
the why do you think that they go
through this loan mechanism so then they
what they seem to be doing is giving you
pay you more on your loan when you do
badly and paying you less on you loan
when you when the pair is doing badly
why does that make any sense well what
could be what could be driving that Dan
stop
that they are
but why don't you just give your money
wire to the law the question here I'm
asking is why didn't I give you a
discount on your loan rather than just
handing you some cash what what what is
that pointing to
desire to feel her I guess I just almost
like a desire not to feel like you gave
me a handout
so one possibility is that it's sort of
God right that's an interesting idea
it's a it's a cover for four you know
I'm giving you the money but it's not so
much that you know people are not seeing
that you know I'm handing you some cash
they're saying that you know I actually
am paying you some money back for a loan
so in that sense it's it's a it's a
cover but it's not clear that that's you
know maybe everybody else also knows
that you're poor it's also clear that
it's so hard you know you had you had a
comment
while that may be different I could
always say that I'm doing badly and you
pay me more on the loan I give you why
would it be any different
maybe because he creates eternity
they should ship between you two
I sort of set up a control agreement
where when I'm not doing well
hey-ya
alone
so you say things what you're saying is
related to what they are saying which is
that one thing that they were alone is
that a loan is suggest that using the
loan suggest that if this is making use
of a pre-existing financial relationship
so an ongoing relationship the
difference between my giving you money
it seems to me mostly that in a sense
these are people who already had a
financial relationship so it's it's the
case that you know I lot of these people
either oh one was the other one money
already and adjusting the terms of that
suggests that it's not so much so in
other words it's not clear that what
this isn't telling us is simply that the
people who have these transactions are
already people who've had a stock
against each other so it's not the case
that so it's it's it's you know you keep
count and say you know it's not clear so
instead of thinking of this as being the
loan as being a a separate financial
product one way to think about it is
that you know we keep accounts and you
know I've done you five favors you've
done me three favors and the net is two
favors and the loan amount really
reflects our netting out of those favors
so we keep so in other words what is
nice about a loan is as a net
I either I owe you or you owe me it's a
net accounting device for keeping track
of who's done who fed how many favors so
that by thinking of it in loan terms it
creates a natural framework for thinking
about this as a kind of a social
accounting device I keep track how do I
keep track of like maybe people also say
well I you know I did you seven favors
and you've known enemy one
I have heard people if they say things
like that so you know the same
psychology it's it's a good way to keep
track thinking about in terms of loan
makes it clear that what you're trying
to do is keep track of off an ongoing
relationship it's a stock you know I
gave you hundred you paid me back fifty
then I give you thirty then you gave me
two hundred and by when I add those up
every stage what do I really care about
is not how many times what happened but
the net amount you owe me and that's a
good way to account for the relationship
so I'm kind of yeah we can keep track of
you know am i someone who owes you or
you are you someone who owes me by sort
of counting that amount and that way we
don't need to keep track of all these
other numbers you know whether was
twenty ones and fifteen another time
it's just one number which is kind of
measures our collective obligation and
the reason that that we would like why
would why would we like to keep track of
the collective obligation
but why does it matter
everything
it's so security for home
so what one 101 one advantage of that
might be that it kind of summarizes you
know my status in the collective system
so it may be that you know everybody
knows I owe I owe you 50 and so in and
then nobody will want to lend me much
more because it looks like I'm just
somebody who takes money from everybody
and never gives them so if you know it's
a good way to keep track off of whether
there's someone who's sort of trying to
beat the system but there's another
world maybe less even simpler reason why
you move on
speak up
why would be to avoid moral hazard
right so it could that's the same
basically the same thing but in some
ways I think there's an even simpler
reason why you may want to keep keep
track of it which is simply it may well
be that I just knew Weezer be someone
else he may want to know you know how
many times has this guy taken from me
and I may want to just put a limit to
that because I know that at some level
I'm gonna die in in 20 years or
something and so I'm going to say look
you know if it's reciprocity so that the
reason I'm giving him is X you know that
he will pay me back eventually then I
want to know whether it's reasonable to
expect that he will you know I'll get
enough back from him so if I if I think
that basically the reason why I'm giving
him the money is because he will
eventually you know give me back the
money when I need it well if my future
is 20 years and I've given him you know
five million dollars I'm unlikely to get
that much back so I want to know roughly
where I am in that transaction because
that's that's the only way that I can
kind of make a rational decision about
whether it's worth continuing
I mean if he owes so I want to if my
reason for me in the relationship is
that I also think that I'm going to get
some papers from him then knowing how
much he already owes me is a way to keep
track of you know how much can I
reasonably expect to get back from him
if it's if that numbers already way past
anything that then I don't need to give
him extra favors to get it get more back
it's some level I I I'm just not going
to be able to collect so then if there's
some kind of rationale so I might want
to limit my exposure to him because in
some sense I know that he's never going
to pay off to invest so much in a
particular process so that's it might be
a useful accounting device so I think
that the the Chris you jury who came up
with this who did the study
interpreter very much was this that they
are keeping track of you know how how
much they owe each other that did
everybody knows roughly you know I do I
owe this guy this much which is within
reasonable limits it's not too much and
therefore I can't expect to get it back
eventually so here's a this is a table
from Chris's Chris's paper and it's just
a very simple point but it's worth
looking at the paper sort of striking so
it's the monthly interest rate there's a
huge numbers that's why it's worth
looking at the monthly interest rate
when the borrower gets no shock he pays
four percentage points less per month
that's a lot right four percentage point
what's what what's four percentage per
month compounded
what's the combined
close to 50% so that's like 50% off you
know so you know you getting like 4% for
months less nothing look at the other
number when the lender has a bad shock
no shock he charges basically 10
percentage points less per month then
when he has a shock that numbers you
know difference will be minus 7.5 and
and 2.6 is basically 10 percentage
points but when he has a shock he
charges 10 percentage points more so
there's a massive numbers I mean those
are like you he the interest rates just
move enormous Lee suggesting that there
is actually substantial resource
transfer that's going on
he chooses so we don't know that I mean
he well we only observe is that the
person pays that much more when when the
lender gets a shot but the difference I
mean just to get the order of magnitude
these are very very large numbers so
these are substantial transfers going on
in both directions on the other hand
there's still 10% off off alone so it's
like you know the stock is much bigger
so these people have a law on going
later with each other and then they they
pay pay they change that number by
having a changing interest rate by a lot
now what what they're also telling us
it's also telling us something about
this scope of this relationship right
because these are people so if if the
way I'm going to get insurance is by
getting even a 10 percentage point
reduction in the interest rate since the
interest rate is 15 percent and I get 10
percentage points off but I owe you $100
how much do I save
say five dollars I was going to pay him
$15 and I now pay five five dollars the
main point is that the amount of
insurance that you can get to this
system is still very limited by the
amount of loan there is because you know
if I'm giving you a discount on a loan
then that depends on the loan amount I
had so if the loan amount was a million
dollars then a discount on that is worth
a lot if these are poor people and their
loan amount net loan amount is ten
dollars then the fact that I'm getting a
discount on the loan is not giving me
that much insurance so the downside of
thinking about it in in loan terms and
in principle risk this this this could
be a relatively small number so I think
these interest rates are high but
they're not high enough to turn a small
number into small number okay so what I
want to do next so that's sort of one
thing to keep in mind I'll come back to
this because I want to talk a little bit
more about other forms of insurance so
one form of insurance we observe is this
law which is the law and that has its
advantage that it's a nice accounting
device I can keep track of what's going
on and it's a disadvantage that you know
indeed if I haven't given you a loan
then I can't help you it's sort of both
through this lawn so if I if there if if
I you only owe me five dollars then it's
not going to be a big transfer because
you know you cannot at most let off the
interest on the five dollars but
interest on five dollars is fifty cents
and that's not going to make a big
difference to me so in general that
limits the scope of the system now what
I'm going to talk about is a big stuff
from Thailand which is different because
it's it's our colleague Robert Townsend
has been studying these villages for
many many years and I'll show you some
data from what is what he's collected
and then we'll we'll see that the way
insurance is offered in Thailand is very
different in principle
so institutional form in Nigeria it's a
loan in Thailand we'll see what it is so
first here's a here's a nice table it's
sort of a fact that I've been saying
many times it just says how much risk to
people bear so what this this table is
each row is a farmer
for different farmers we have they don't
have data for every farmer but two
things to note one is look at the best
here in the worst year for these farmers
there's somewhat correlated were not
perfectly right the best year for some
farmers was 85 the worst year for some
farmers was 85 the best year here for
some farmers were 88 the worst year for
some farmers was 88 why am i emphasizing
the correlation
these are all within the same village I
mean one village one I emphasize the
correlation yeah so then there is scope
for insurance you can I can ensure you
only if you know we don't what get into
trouble at the same time so the worst
year of the for one farmer is not the
worst year for the other former the
second thing is look at the magnitudes
that last column column is the
percentage kind of you look at the
harvest amounts the best year the worst
year the differences are massive
it's just the amounts I'm just I all
just want to look at you the amount the
amount so impressive because think about
you know you you you got an income of
fifty one year and four hundred and
fifteen the next yeah those are big
differences
anything else that strikes you
well maybe this may be difficult to see
but one thing that's interesting is that
if you look at the it's not that the
people who have or average less harvest
the risk seems to be independent of that
so richer people seem to have roughly
the same risk as poorer people so
everybody seems to be exposed to risk
it's not that the rich people have less
risk like B they take the maximum
maximum our harvest theta maximum
harvest the bigger we people are the
bigger maximum harvest don't look this
table is nice too it goes back to
answering then the implied question
what's going on what's the source of
risk and that's sort of what
sorry no yeah this is the same muscles
of the previous table
same the numbers P 35 36 these are the
same households and always in the same
village and this is asking why did you
face risk and again mostly it has to do
with whether though for some people
there's one person who says that insects
is the biggest source of risk
help
once bastard but also someone's were
scared yeah that's that's someone else
want to suggest the answer
I mean I think it indicates that
it's to potential attitude watering
could be the answer maybe some of these
fields are derogated but judging by the
variation
all these fields you knew would have the
greatest irrigation the fact they're
still pretty big fluctuation of Prague
not the answer
Manning is indicative that there's other
factors at work and everybody will we've
been saying that it's rain sure I mean
maybe they don't realize I mean I think
if they realize what their what the
other farmer was doing I'm going to be
some more successful they'd probably try
to do it so maybe I need a to realize
that fertilizer maybe that they got on
what
disease that could be could be different
crops yeah so most of this explanation
is that some of them are doing very
different crops so it might be some
crops hate water you know and others
really like my cry sweetly adores water
but chillies hate water so you know so
their crops which you know if you get
too much rain you get lower output and
crops which are which are very you know
output is always increasing in rain and
so one possible explanation is that they
were planting planting different crops
so I planted we both plant at the same
time I'm planting a crop which will hurt
if if the rain is bad and will do well
when the rain is good and the other way
round so that's one possibility
other possibilities that they just micro
climates that the the rain is rain is
sort of you you get after all what
matters is not so much rain as such but
rain at the right time so I I plant on a
particular day my saplings I've just
come out of the ground
that's when I need rain when the crow
the plant is young and if I flap so the
it may well be that the rain on those
five days was very good but then the guy
who planted later he thought the rains
would be better in five days and then
the rains were really not better they
were really bad so it may very well be
that there is either geographical
variation in rainfall within a local
area or just over time so that the you
know I plant it on a particular day I
needed the rain in ten days after that
when the saplings came out I got the
rain
you didn't get the rain so I think both
of those are plausible so I just wanted
you to look at this because I talk keep
talking a risk but this is sort of a
much better way to look at it you just
see the magnitudes of it and the sources
of it so I thought this table - very
nice now what he goes want to do in in
paper is asking what do how do people
deal with risk and so he studies
described in three villages there within
very close to each other to the point
where one of the villages people
actually use the financial institutions
in the other villages so they're very
close to each other and exactly in this
area where the rainfall was measured so
the risk is roughly what you saw so the
risk is about what you you know we got a
sense of this risk and in Nigeria we saw
that people respond by borrowing from
each other here in this particular
village there are five different funds
for so there's a village savings fund
and the village savings fund is actually
an equity fund these guys actually pay
you a different rate of return depending
on what the borrowers were willing to
pay so I put in money into this fund and
then you come and borrow I can charge
you a I'll you know you willing to pay
20 percent then that money gets rolled
back to me so it's a fund which has a
variable interest which depends on the
village demand levels well what does
that done what what what what do you
think should happen today to the
interest rate when the rainfall - in
that fund when the rainfall is good or
bad
how did Barry
go up win the rainforest go down
so one possibility is go up because when
the rain when the rainfall is good
productivity is high people are willing
to buy more inputs to produce and that
would mean that the rainfall is that
good for insurance about for insurance
yeah
let's go for insolence because the
people are getting high productivity
shocks are borrowing but you could
imagine the opposite which is fun with a
variable interest rate where we only
borrow from it when we are desperate
then you might say the demand for those
funds being particularly when there is
rainfall is bad because we all try to
borrow from that too to survive and at
that point very few people are going to
lend the interest rate is going to go up
that's going to be bad for the insurance
so it depends very much a variable
rather a fixed interest fund a variable
interest fund can be either good or bad
for insurance then there is a fun for
purchase of pigs pigs here the interest
rate is fixed but there's a roll over
provision roll over provision is if you
if you are in trouble and you can't pay
then I can let you keep the loan for
longer you pay more but you don't have
to pay back now is that good for
insurance or bad
right assuming that the person is going
to pay it back it's good for Richard
rollovers are good for insurance there's
a fund for purchase of fertilizer so
each of these is like almost like a is
it like a proper financial institution
at the village level so in this village
there is a you know you can go the
leader has organized a bunch of funds
and you can you you can sub you can save
money to buy pigs in this fund and right
now if I've saved money and you want to
buy pigs you can borrow from this fund
and likewise there's a money of fun for
buying fertilizer a rice bank where the
rice I grow I can store and when I need
rice I can take rice from it and there's
a Health Care Fund where we each put in
money and if some if somebody gets sick
he gets to spend it so this is a village
it is rich with financial institutions
these are not loans in particular the
healthcare fund is a is a or the roll
over is is something where I'm making a
direct transfer from to the people
people who are more hurting but I mean I
guess it's somewhat but it's it's not
bilateral loans these are kind of
financing from a financial institution
so this is the main point I'm making
here is that here you see a very
different source of insurance this is
organized through collective action
everybody is getting together and
lending to everybody else
now easy he goes down a few more miles
from may walk to a village called soft
walk and what does he see well on paper
it looks very similar but here's the
problem all the loans are in default I'm
not alone at all but a lot of loans are
in default is this good or bad for
insurance
anybody else
why sell for a default that for
insurance
but maybe the person was defaulting is
the one who needs to not pay so clear
the default is bad for insurance problem
is with if this default then nobody will
funny and put money into the into the
bank so if if people Willie
so default is in a sense a form of
insurance right I allow you to not pay
when you can't pay but if there's a lot
of default and I think that's Merrifield
then I may not put money into the bank
so again it's not clear whether in which
way it goes but he interprets this as
saying that these places these banks
nobody's putting money into them so
these banks are kind of defunct yeah
or we could imagine a world where that's
exactly how we provide insurance so we
each you know imagine that the rule is
year one if you have a shock this year
you borrow even yeah two if you again
have a shock then you default we write
it off happens in one time out of ten or
one time or twenty but you know that's
this good it can happen to any of us and
when is really bad and I've had two
shocks in a row it's better for me to
not have to pay back they knew to give
me a yet another loan there's no
particular reason why default would be
bad for insurance if we could make sure
that the default is limited but it
counts that into its think of that as
being the insurance company is losing
that money but remember when the
insurance company makes a payment it
also loses money
so this think of it as a form of payment
default could just be a form of
insurance because I could be paying
people in the form of default you don't
have to pay fine you don't have any
money you'll never pay that's a
perfectly legitimate form of insurance
it just question is whether it's
deliberate in which case it will be too
much operated and in that case the
system won't work yeah
I guess the lot is relative to what what
they are willing what they were planning
for there's nothing else about a lot of
default right it's just what you're
planning for I could plan for you know
one loan out of file will be defaulted
and the others will just absorb that
loan loss and might be fine it may be a
form of insurance default is a natural
form of insurance so was understanding
that it is none nothing obviously bad
about default if it's if it's completely
just I have no choice I default that's a
perfectly good way to insure myself we
say then I don't need to pay when I'm in
a really bad shape it's when I start
using there's an excuse to not pay that
that it makes a difference yeah
so I cannot deal with that seems like
we're arguing outwards so I I I think
the default just means I don't pay the
loan and when I don't pay the loan that
might very well be desirable now as you
can see their view is a bit that is not
actually necessarily a good idea to
collect because they're basically there
they're taking the view that you know
these people are defaulting are
defaulting because they need to default
so it's not clear what default means
here and that's what it's worth
understanding the third village then he
walks down to a third village the third
village is a few few miles down and this
is none of these funds exist so one
village all the funds are working well
in the second village there's a lot of
default the funds are still there
third village no funds except one and
you are in a Nigerian mode where you
just borrowing from each other so what's
the advantage of a fund over borrowing
from each other let me see this someone
else wants to answer what's that run
into a fund over borrowing from each
other
why
it's a way to pull many more people so
that's that's the advantage oh so why do
you think what what do you think is
going on why do these villages which are
very similar have same kind of risk next
to each other have different very
different patterns think about what it
takes for such an institution to
institution to exist
right so you need to have so the way
this one of these funds works is by
saying that I'm going to put money into
it now because I can get money into it
in the future what does it assume that
that there is a future so in other words
if I think that everybody else is going
to default today I should default as
well because there will be no fue fund
in the future right so this is a classic
kind of problem of anything that's sort
of sustained by the future it depends on
there being a future so imagine that I
think that for this is this is the
problem that right now a lot of
microcredit organizations are facing
microcredit Organization promises you
alone if you pay back your loan now
suppose you suppose you don't you think
that nobody will else will pay back
their loan what's going to happen to the
microcredit organization
it's going to go bankrupt if it goes
bankrupt what's going to happen to your
future alone does it exist so basically
if this fund if everybody else expects
people to default in the future then I
should default now so these is rationale
if everybody else is expected to default
it is rational for me to default if
everybody is expected to pay back in the
future there's a rationale for me to pay
back because then the fund will be there
for a long time so I think this is the
this is the sort of the reason why funds
so all these kind of informal
institutions are fragile because they
rely on this kind of coordination I only
want to repay if everybody else wants to
repay or at least as long as enough
people want to repay that the money will
the fund will be going if I expect that
lots of people will default in the
future I should default now because a
fund is going to go out of business I'm
not going to get anything out of it in
the future so I might as well just stop
having anything to do with it so it
totally depends on trust if I believe
that everybody else is going to behave
well then I should behave well if I
think that everybody else is going to
behave badly then it's over in some
sense that's one central weakness of
these kinds of informal institutions
they rely on the expectation that
expectation that I am going to behave
well in the future yeah
but then you can't borrow a game then
they can say look you know you've
defaulted you're never going to oh you
didn't pay the money and when you need
it - you are supposed to pay money into
the fund you didn't pay now you're out
no but if you come and ask me for money
to put money into the fund and I know
that everybody else is planning your
default I'm never going to do it and if
I have if I ever get a loan out of it
I'm going to default as soon as I can
because I know everybody else is
planning to default so default in these
kinds of institutions default is
entirely sort of self-fulfilling so if I
if I expect default I'll have default if
I expect people to behave bad well we'll
probably all behave well so the probably
the reason why these villages are so
different is because of this expectation
'el mechanism which is very important to
understand and it's true very lots of
financial institutions they they rely on
our future compliance to work and that's
why you know for example I mean even
even banks to some extent right if I
decide that I'm going to withdraw my
money from the bank
everybody else is going to be demanding
money from the bank tomorrow what should
i do today
I should redo it today
that's a bank run so a lot of financial
institutions have exactly this feature
and that's why it's not so surprising to
see that some villages have very good
institutions rich set of institutions
others don't the fact that when some
villages have default is the same
reasoning if once people start
defaulting everybody is going to start
defaulting yeah
sure so it could very well be that
another thing that this sells us is that
for example the leader matters so the
leader is someone who's who who can
enforce punishments in the village so if
I default suppose I'm supposed to pay
back and I know I can't pay back but you
know I I just refused to do it if the
leader can basically ostracize you have
me ask ostracized then in some sense I'm
not going to do it and then given that
I'm not going to do it everybody else is
willing to pay into the fund so it's
going to be huge leverage from effective
leadership that's the other actually
conclusion of this paper is that there's
a good leader in in in the first village
and he was very important in setting up
these institutions that he made them
work so this is yeah
I can't tell you who said that the the
leader was wearing you know energetic
etc this gives a description of the
leader but doesn't tell me what he was
doing so much ok so we already talked
about moral hazard other limits of
insurance so one limit of insurance but
I wanted to emphasize that because I
wanted to emphasize that this is not
just a limit of insurance it's a limit
of any institution that is not enforced
by legal punishments anything that's not
enforced by legal punishments is fragile
all the ways it depends on it will work
if it works if it doesn't work it
doesn't work right that's sort of the
main meaning point of that example that
you know if we all stop paying money
into the fund then the fund will die so
we I might as well take my money and run
that's that's that's true of not just an
insurance of any other kind of
institution the moral hazard we've
talked about we'll skip moral hazard
here's here's a another problem with
informal insurance this is all of what
we were talking about a bit but
so this is this we've been sort of
talking about implicitly you know
default but we've also been talking
about one thing that insurance and
arrangement demands is that when it's
your turn to pay you pay sometimes you
get money from the fund sometimes you
pay them into the fund you have to be
willing to pay money into the fund right
that's what makes it keeps it going why
do you want to keep putting money in the
fund we said this already but just to
repeat
why would I today I'm not I am rich I
want to put money into the fund so that
somebody else can take it out why would
I want to do it what does anyone want to
put money into a fund sorry yeah
eventually I'm going to either you pay
me some return on the fund but if it has
to have an insurance component then it
has to be that in return I get on it
is lower than the market return because
otherwise you know the they could have
could have borrowed from the market it
doesn't provide any insurance so it I it
can't be just because I want to get the
money back because then it must be
because I expect that I will be able to
borrow from the fund in the future as
well so I will be willing to put money
into a fund which pays lower than market
rates which is what insurances
insurances that I'm willing to lend to
someone at lower than market rates so
that so that he doesn't when he's in bad
shape he doesn't suffer too much that's
what the insurance
right so exactly so
Wow one reason they may want to do it is
that they they feel the same need as so
why would I put money and what's an
insurance when the insurance fund is a
fund where I put in money so other
people can be helped in return for the
fact that some they will put in money
and I will be helped
why would I put in money now because I
expect to be helped in the future so
what are the kinds of people who won't
don't want to join that fund
you already gave one answer which is
people who are rich they don't need
expect to hit get helped so that's why
you're going to see that if there's a
lot of inequality in the village you
unlike to need to see a fund because you
know the rich don't really think that
they can be helped by the poor if they
ever need money to read them you know a
hundred thousand dollars the poor won't
have it and if otherwise they won't need
money yeah
always was
the future
right so you need to be forward-looking
to be willing to behave well in a
forward-looking if you if I always think
that well I'll I'll just not pay now and
you know whatever happens in the future
then that's not going to work you need
to be forward-looking and and what's the
point of a migration why is migration
important
you say you have hitting the brigade's
you need to be in the biz to benefit
from the funny if I expect to go away
I'm not going to be I don't know whether
I'm going to be here to benefit from
this fund so if there's a lot of
mobility in a place then everything
falls apart so if you are nearer so one
of the things that it's villages that
are closer to the road to a big city
find it harder to ensure each other why
because they don't everybody there has a
link to the city so they don't know
whether they're whether they're going to
help from the village or they're going
to get to go to the city and get a job
there and so given that I am not
committed to being in the village it's
very hard to give me insurance so on so
all of these things you need low
mobility low inequality and
forward-looking people yeah right it's
actually the point a bad one with a bank
account bank account would undermine
insurance why because in a bank account
I now can get high return on my savings
so I'm going to be more tempted to say
when I have money it's more tempting for
me to put it in the bank account rather
and put it in this fund which is going
to pay me a lower return because it's
going to help out other people so any
outside options that are you provide to
financial development might undermine
local institutions so you might actually
see worse institutions where the
financial system is better from formerly
yeah
you say that market rate was higher than
unemployment
yes yes
oh absolutely the other way round
questions who do you borrow money from
the poor the bank does it makes it too
easy for me today I have money and you
need money I'm gonna put my money in the
bank that's why you can't get money from
the fund this fund is two-way street
right I need to put in money you need to
take out money
I am only willing to put it as my
options of putting money elsewhere get
better it's gonna be harder and harder
to force me to put money into the bank
into the fund especially right let me be
clear what are we saying there's a fund
what's the fun the fund is that I I put
money into it I get lower than market
rates why because I want to give that
money to someone else who needs it
desperately providing insurance there's
also a bank which pays the market rate
now as the market rate gets goes it's
higher it's harder and harder for the
guy who has money today to not feel
tempted to put his money into the bank
sure so maybe the bank is not actually
available but the bank is available to
you that might actually bad for
insurance is that sort of maybe
surprising that you know a bank shows up
and that actually undermines people's
ability to ensure each other it is too
easy to now park your money elsewhere
other reasons why informal insurance
doesn't work very well we also talked
about we talked about the coordination
quite a lot already you know if if I
expect to default on the fund then you
will default to this coordination also
you know farmers you know you would
expect that these these funds only work
because I have some I know when you
really need money and when you don't
because otherwise you can always say I
need money so you don't let in people
who are very isolated so people who are
not in the village network don't get
into these funds they tend to be off
people who are relatively well connected
to the village community why because you
know I need to know who know whether
you're lying or not and if you are you
live next to me I know that you know yes
your cow died or whatever your Pig was
you know eaten up by a I know tiger or
something I know whatever happens to
pigs but you know if if you if I if I
live don't you live far away how do I
know what whether you are you you're in
trouble or not so it tends to be that
this is the tends to be concentrated
about people who know each other the
scope of the insurance is limited yeah
finally in some sense this is a very bad
mechanism for dealing with shocks which
affect everybody in the village
obviously you know if there is one
blight in the village which affects
everybody this is not going to help
anybody
there's nobody gonna help each other so
that's so that goes back takes us back
to where we will at the end of last the
last lecture which is saying on the
other hand formal insurance markets are
hard to develop that's where we ended
last time he said formal insurance
markets are hard to develop why because
people are suspicious of these products
they don't understand them they're too
complicated you know they have all these
extrusions which you don't understand so
you don't like it I was telling the
story of all these women who got really
upset because one of their friends
husband died but the medical health
insurance didn't pay for it health
insurance was actually right in not pay
for it in formal terms because there the
contract said will only pay for people
who go to the hospital he died at home
but that didn't mean that they they
thought that well something bad happened
why aren't you paying for it so that was
a so they basically got very upset so
insurance is confusing its formal
insurance has rules which you if your
semi-literate you don't understand it
tends to be quite limited in other ways
because unlike I know a lot about my
neighbors I know if his cow was eaten a
by a by a tiger for example on the other
insurance company doesn't know anything
about my neighbor so it can't insure
things like that but it's a very nice
story that so this is how insurances I
bring up the example because it's a good
good example so good ensuring cows is a
big issue in every developing country
with cows are a major asset in some
countries like in Botswana it's the
single biggest asset other than diamonds
turns out so the only two major assets
in Botswana are their cows and diamonds
but most people have cows very few
people have diamonds so so so so so the
insurance companies have been trying for
a long time to insure cows problem is
that you know what you you insure cows
were saying if the cow dies I'll pay you
money but it's convenient for cows to
die because they turn into steaks and
steaks and you know many people like
them so if they have the Creator huge
moral hazard problem so this company
thought we had a very clever idea
they said this they said that if you
claim that your cow has died you to
bring me the ear of the cow that Cal you
have to cut his ear off and show it to
me on her ear off I don't know what
happened
all right they create so imagine my cow
dies I'm not insured what do I do I cut
off his ear and sell it to somebody's
insured
it created a robust market for cow ears
everybody was buying cow ears to go to
the bank and collect insurance so that's
that's your primary problem with with
sort of formal insurance they don't know
where the Kyodai they have to figure out
a way to track that down that's not easy
to do because of this this ear problem
so so basically we are between a rock
and a hard place
people don't understand insurance
insurance is incomplete at best because
you know you can't really insure cows
because I don't know when your cow died
or not on the other hand if we look at
insurance that comes from a community
the people who have the information that
is to be limit it for these other
reasons we discuss so we're kind of
between a rock and a hard place so I
think the basic I think the message of
this this particular area is that this
is classic area where a government
providing some kind of insurance that's
not expected to break even is much more
efficient because you know if it is
something that is so rather than
thinking of insurance which is market
supplied for example a government scheme
which says you can come to work whenever
you you need to work and we'll pay you a
minimum wage it's very effective because
you know if I pay you lower less enough
I mean the wage is low enough you're
never going to take that job if you if
you are if you do you have a real real
real job you'll only take it when you're
desperate so that's a very efficient way
to provide insurance because now the
problem is that that's not going to fund
itself it's a one-way one-way
payment for the government but on the
other hand it provides make sure that
anybody was really desperate can find a
job and therefore can say secures them
so in something this is a classic area
or if you think of an insurance where
people don't understand the product well
they don't want to buy it because they
don't understand product but if you
provide it free they'll take it so if
the government we're to actually
subsidize insurance that might be a very
good way to help poor people because
it's it's something that they don't
understand it's good for them they don't
the demand is too low because they don't
know how to understand interpret it
on the other hand they will get the
benefits from it so it's it's I think
insurance is a very very natural place
for public intervention and I think
that's that's sort of what makes it
really interesting is how to design good
insurance products for poor people which
possibly combine some advantage of the
market and some advantages of the off of
public funding so for example instead of
the government providing health care
maybe everybody should have health
insurance with some you know
appropriately designed coverage and
maybe that should be provided free to
people if they don't understand the
value of it that's fine in the end sick
people are a burden of the government so
they might as well provide it X ex ante
if you want to providing a job to
everybody work fair is what the word
people use in the u.s. to people who
want a job is a way to make sure that
people when they desperate they have
some way of generating income and that
the wage at that income doesn't go down
because everybody's demanding a job so
in some sense it's a way to secure
people and it's a way to do it
efficiently to make sure that the right
people go to it you don't give them
money you want to give them a job
because a job has the advantage that you
get targeting so it's something it's a
good domain to think about public policy
well I'll stop here will Mike talk a
little bit more